okay let's start with something that a
lot of people have asked me to talk
about on the show this is really
interesting the latest
right-wing buzzword that's getting
people fired up and angry
is critical race theory republicans are
absolutely and completely against the
teaching of critical race theory
in schools they want to ban it they
believe it's terrible it might even be
communist or socialist it's really
really bad
but they don't actually know what it is
check out this interview that mark
lamont hill did with former georgia
congressman vernon jones a trumpian
favorite who is really against critical
race theory but he has
no idea what it is check this out what
is critical race theory
well actually i think it's different
depends on who's teaching
and how they're teaching i think you can
agree with that uh we were taught that
christopher columbus discovered america
well you and i both know that
christopher columbus got lost
people are already living here but there
are those who are using their own
ideology
and their own party affiliation to go to
the extreme and that's all i'm trying to
address here
but what does that what does that have
to do with critical race theory
let me just pause i'm trying to
understand though
you oppose critical race theory which i
understand i'm just asking
what is it what is the thing you define
it like for example if i said i'm
against creationism
i would say creationism is x y and z
right
if i said i was against the teaching of
sex education i said well sex education
is x y and z and i'd have a basis for it
what is critical race theory well
first of all again i can tell you what
is left of you to understand i can't
make you understand
fact of it is the critical race theory
even on this basis
should not be taught in our schools
period now if you can't understand what
is it
and if you want to debate well to me
what it does
to me my interpretation as well as many
others not what it does what is it
how do you define it i mean that has to
define critical race theory
because my audience may not know
well you don't know and you have i said
obviously you don't know and you haven't
told your audience
but again how i see it and how i don't
know
receive well well then what is it then
no what is it then okay well i'm happy
to answer that for you
but your answer you're saying just
answer i'll tell you what
i will absolutely debate okay i'm
waiting for you to answer go ahead and
answer it i i
i i i will just hold on one second
you're you're saying that on day one
on day one here's the question first
answer the first
question i promise i'll answer your
questions so you get the picture vernon
jones just
doesn't know what it is that's just one
example but this is the bottom line
they continue to attack critical race
theory without actually indicating that
they know what it is
when they're asked what it is they seem
to have no idea
or they say critical race theory is the
idea that every white person is a white
supremacist oppressor
now we should understand what critical
race theory
is and i want to be really clear that
critical race theory
is not my primary lens through which i
view the world i find it reductionist
but i'm going to tell you what critical
race theory is
and then you can research more you can
decide whether you think it's an
accurate lens or whether it should be
part of your uh world view okay the way
i see
critical race theory is a sort of race
reductionism now if you've heard the
term
class reductionism there's a very simple
analogy
to at least give us an initial basic
understanding of critical race theory
although it's not nuanced enough and i
admit that
class reductionists believe that at some
fundamental level any division
any problem any conflict any inequality
in society
in politics in an economy even if it
seems
it might be caused by many things is
actually about class
something that to a class reduction is
something that looks like a racial issue
uh to a class reductionist it's really a
problem
caused by class differences and the
racial factors
may just be confounding or they may be
coincidental or they may not even be
relevant so
to make a very rough analogy to
give us a start in understanding
critical race theory critical race
theory
would analogously argue that what might
seem like a class problem or an economic
problem
or a political problem that it is
actually
fundamentally a problem of race and
racism
in the u.s specifically it would be
racism generally
by white people against non-white people
in particular against
black americans now that's the most
basic explanation it's far more detailed
as an area of academic research now for
30 years and really even more than that
uh the roots of critical race theory are
in the 60s and 70s
but um without getting into you know a
more nuanced definition would include
the idea of creating subgroups of humans
developing law
and systems that are inherently racist
and designed to maintain these
inequalities
between whites and non-whites and you
can use that analysis when you look at
any system you can look at the education
system through the lens of critical race
theory or the election system and on and
on
now there are undoubtedly many ways in
which
aspects of critical race theory are
completely accurate
where i disagree with critical race
theory much the same way i disagree with
class reductionism
is that i don't think anything is quite
so simple on a planet of 7 billion
people
in a country of 331 million like the u.s
we can never really say this
issue is solely informed by
one thing whether it's race whether i've
never found an issue
where race is the one lens through which
we understand it or
class is the one lens or geography is
the one
it's just never been that way on any
issue i've studied but this is not about
my view
this is about the reality that the very
people angrily denouncing critical race
theory
have no idea what it even is now i want
to say one other thing about that
this is not uncommon think about the
usage
of the term socialist during the last
presidential election
i've asked lots of these people when i
interview them or when they call in or
when
you know whatever what do you mean
socialist and they have no idea what it
means
but they use it and they believe joe
biden is one now cartoonishly as one
example here's what happened when
conservative
jessie lee peterson brought it up when i
visited his studio in los angeles
and the topic of socialism came up
during the trump administration take a
look
because it's the straight white
conservative christian man
who's holding the country together oh if
it wasn't for them america would be
associated with society already it would
be what a socialist
society how would it become if you see
if you notice the avid black man has no
authority no power the mexican doesn't
have any
is that white straight conservative
christian man
that is preventing them from turning
this country
into a you know socialist society but so
here let me ask you about this
i'm not a socialist myself i'm a social
just to be clear i'm i don't i'm not
advocating for social media
i don't know that many actual socialists
like who would
who where's the big desire for the u.s
to become socialists
if you look at the democratic party
there's almost no socialists in the
democratic socialist
communist party now that's one socialist
idea from the democratic
socialized healthcare no that's a social
social democracy
program no denmark socialist and if you
notice that barack obama
the father messiah you know he's the
father messiah right
i don't know anything about that well i
big mama michelle uh he tried to turn
america into a socialist society what's
one example of a socialist policy that
he had
uh socialized healthcare he didn't do
that he did for-profit obamacare taking
care of everybody
how so by getting rid of jobs many
people mostly took care of people about
getting
rid of full-time jobs and they had to
work two part-time jobs in order to
survive so
you don't even understand the talking
points the rest stopped working and just
went and depended
and relied on the government free obama
phones
that's socialism socialism so how can
you obamacare
socialism i want to ask a real question
i'm asking you a real question
obama phones are not socialism no i'll
answer your question let me ask you a
real
i the arguments against places like
venezuela and cuba
and other so-called socialist countries
are that
no one has anything no one can afford
anything
there's no technology there's no food
but you're saying that
cell phones for people are socialism
yeah is that that's your argument yes
right that's an example of it yeah
so the point is there's no difference
here they don't know what socialism is
they don't know what critical race
theory is the first step
in every single one of these
conversations should be
ask them to define the terms and you
will very quickly see
that they have no idea what they are
talking about
one of our sponsors is curiosity stream
letting my audience try it free for an
entire
month i love curiosity stream perfect
for people
like me or anybody who watches the david
pakman show curiosity stream is kind of
like netflix for documentaries it's a
streaming service with
thousands of documentaries from some of
the best filmmakers
many are exclusive to curiosity stream
including documentaries on politics
science history
everything the curiosity stream app is
great
i use it on my tv phone and ipad
i just watched as i told you uh very
recently
engineering the future very very
interesting
about potential future technologies
and they always have the newest and most
popular documentaries
they have amazing ones that i can't find
on other platforms and
curiosity stream is just 2.99 a month
or 19.99 for a whole year but you
can try it totally free for one month
when you go to curiositystream.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman